merci madame la Présidente je ne seraai
pas très
long manifestement une partie des
interventions qui ont succédé à ma prise
de parole avait été écrite avant ma
prise de parole c'est le jeu on sait
comment ça fonctionne je voulais revenir
sur quelques points qui m'ont semblé
importants évidemment notamment
s'agissant de nos agriculteurs j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire tout à l'heure
dans les T prochains jours nous
annoncerons de nouv mesure en soutien à
nos agriculteurs nous avons échangé vous
le savez avec leurs représentants
pendant 3h30 hier il y a des discussions
continue qui se poursuivent avec eux
entre nos équipes entre nous pour
avancer et je sais que c'est attendu et
je sais que c'est attendu depuis
longtemps pour certaines d'entre elles
je veux revenir sur certains points qui
ont été évoqués dire à Monsieur marlex
que sur la question des tourbières des
zones humides j'ai bien annoncé vendredi
dernier que je donnais consigne à
l'ensemble des préfets de mettre ce
travail en pause le temps de revoir les
choses avec les représentants des
agriculteurs j'ai bien mesuré le malaise
qui existait autour de cette question
sur la question des
surtranspositions il y a un engagement
qui a été pris par le président en 2017
qui a été tenu pas d'interdiction sans
solution et nous avons assumé de
présenter un projet de loi et ça n'a pas
été simple je me souviens des débats
politiques qui sont intervenus dans cet
hémicycle nous avons assumé précisément
sur la betterave d'autoriser de
réautoriser les néonicotinoïdes parce
que la filière betterave était en train
de couler les néonicotinoïdes pour la
betterave avaient été interdit par la
majorité sous François Hollande sans
sans qu'à l'époque la majorité se
préoccupe une seule seconde de savoir
s'il y avait des solutions de
substitution nous sommes élus en 2017 on
se rend compte qu'il y a pas de
substitution on a assumé de réautoriser
les néonicotinoïdes pour la filière
betterave qui sinon serait se serait
écroulé et moi j'assume de dire j'assume
de dire que quand vous avez à
l'initiative d'une agence si
indépendante soit-elle une
décision de d'interdiction d'une
molécule sans se préoccuper de savoir ce
qui se passe au niveau européen et ce
qui est décidé au niveau européen c'est
un problème j'assume de le dire et donc
nous devons regarder comment nous avons
une organisation qui fonctionne mieux de
ce point de vuel sur égalim je suis de
très près nous vont de très près avec
mes ministres avec Bruno Leem notamment
on en parlait aussi hier avec les
organisations d'agriculteurs les
discussions qui sont en cours notamment
sur le lait que vous avez évoqué moi je
veux simplement rappeler qu'avant les
lois égalim c'est la loi LME qui
s'appliquait qui donnait les pleins
pouvoirs à la grande distribution et je
nentend pas un seul agriculteur nous
dire que les lois à Galim n'ont pas
constitué un progrès ou qu' faudrait
revenir en arrière ce qu' nous disent ce
qu'il nous disent c'est qu'il faut
améliorer le
fonctionnement des galimes il faut
améliorer le fonctionnement des galimes
faire davantage de contrôle et prendre
des mesures on en a parlé aussi hier
avec les organisations d'agriculteur des
mesures pour la rendre plus efficace
notamment du point de vue évidemment de
la rémunération de nos agriculteurs mais
nous sommes prêts vraiment prêts à le
faire sur les jchers ça fait des mois
que Marc fen est mobilisé auprès de la
Commission européenne on a rallié 22
pays européens autour de nous et je le
dis je crois que nous allons obtenir
cette semaine je l'espère en tout cas
mais j'ai vu des signaux compr
médiatique de la commission aujourd'hui
nous allons obtenir une nouvelle
dérogation sur le sujet et à ce propos
je veux dire au rassemblement national
et à Madame Le Pen puisque vous avez
vous-même mis en avant le sujet des
votes au Parlement européen que quand
vous dénoncez les nouvelles règles sur
les jachers elles sont issues des
nouvelles règles de la PAC que vos
députés au Parlement européen ont voté
vos députés au Parlement européen on
voté pour si si c'est la réalité je je
je
vous votez vous votez les règles de la
pack que vous critiquez mais vous ne
votez pas les budgets de la PAC que vous
demandez c'est une incohérence absolue
c'est à se demander si vos députés
savent ce qu'il votent au niveau
européen c'est à se demander si
sincèrement vos députés savent ce qu'ils
votent parce que la réalité c'est que
vous nous parlez de protection vous nous
parlez d'indépendance vous nous parlez
de notre industrie nous avons porté au
niveau européen une taxe carbone au
frontières
ça faait 20 ans que notamment dans
l'industrie en Europe on se battait pour
une taxe carbone aux frontières vos
députés l'ont pas voté qu'on est de
l'acier chinois qui arrive au même prix
que l'acier européen ça n'a pas l'air de
vous poser le moindre problème nous
avons assumé de porter ce mécanisme
européens à nos frontières vous venez
nous déclarer ici et dans les médias
qu'il faut renoncer aux exportations aux
échanges internationaux à tout accord de
libre échange vous irez expliquer à nos
éleveurs de port en Bretagne qui exporte
notamment 30 % de leur production et qui
exporte en Chine vous irez l'expliquer à
nos viticulteurs à ceux qui produisent
du cognac à ceux qui produisent des
produits qui sont massivement exportés
vous irez l'expliquer Madame Le Pen ça a
l'air de vous déranger que je vous mette
en face malheureusement de la réalité
vous irez expliquer à nos producteurs
laitiers qui exportent massivement là
aussi pour 4 milliards en dehors de
l'Union Européenne notamment via le CTA
que vous appelez à dénoncer vous irez
leur expliquer nous nous sommes
cohérents quand un accord est bon pour
nos agriculteurs et qu'il est
suffisamment protecteur pour nos
agriculteurs nous assumons de le
soutenir quand un accord est mauvais et
c'est le cas pour Mercosur nous assumons
nous assumons de nous y opposer et nous
continuerons à le faire c'est ça la
cohérence votre cohérence c'est que vous
êtes tellement contre tout que vous
refusez de voter
tellement contre tout qu'à la fin vous
en finissez par ne plus défendre les
intérêts de notre
pays quand on propose de
soutenir l'Ukraine de sanctionner les
oligarques russes qui ont participé à
l'agression de l'Ukraine là c'est pareil
il ne faut pas compter sur votre soutien
et ceux de vos députés européens je
pourrais en parler longuement je ne le
ferai pas parce que l'essentiel ici
c'est de réaffirmer et de dire
l'engagement qui est le nôtre qui est
celui du président de la République en
ce moment même au niveau européen et ça
sera encore le cas jeudi dans le cadre
du Conseil européen de faire progresser
les choses au service de notre
agriculture évidemment que c'est dur
évidemment que c'est difficile
évidemment qu'il y a un certain nombre
de cas on n'arrive pas à convaincre tout
le monde et mener tout le monde autour
genou c'est ça la difficulté la solution
de facilité c'est la vôre c'est de dire
on s'oppose à tout mais à la fin ça fait
progresser quoi ça fait progresser quoi
pour nos
agriculteurs ça leur permet quoi
oui je me tourne aussi vers vous c'est
aussi la solution qui est la vôtre
pardon mais vous avez là-dessus une
forme de cohérence aussi et vous vous
rejoignez dans la posture nous onurera à
se battre pour nos agriculteurs nous
aurons l'occasion avec Marc F d'annoncer
des choses très concrètes dans les
heures et dans les jours qui VI nous
serons rendez-vous pour soutenir nos
agriculteurs et heureusement que nous
sommes là pour les accompagner merci
beaucoup monsieur le Premier ministre